cannabis ist neben alkohol und tabak die
beliebteste droge in deutschland wie
wirkt sie was sind die gefahren und
warum ist sie eigentlich verboten
das jetzt in klicks um science und
fiction ja das ist cannabis genauer die
getrockneten blütenstände der
cannabispflanze
und genau das wird marihuana genannt und
die berauschende wirkung kommt durch thc
das darin enthalten ist
petra hydro cannabinoid das ist eine
substanz die einen botenstoff im gehirn
sehr stark ähnelt und egal auf welche
weise jetzt cannabis eingenommen wird
wird das gehirn mit thc überschwemmt und
thc doktern überall da an den rezeptoren
der synapsen der nervenzellen an wo es
passt und das sind ja die kommunikations
antennen der nervenzellen
das heißt die kommunikation wird stark
geändert zwischen den zellen
damit das möglichst effektiv geschieht
wird cannabis gerne hochkonzentriert mit
tabak gemischt in einer solchen bong
geraucht
das thc gelangt so in sehr hoher menge
extrem schnell über die lunge in den
körper und kann dort unser gehirn
beeinflussen
das heißt signalwege werden jetzt
manipuliert so genannte signalkaskaden
und die freisetzung vieler botenstoffe
wird verändert dem rausch sind tür und
tor geöffnet in dem moment wo man diese
anregenden signale durch das thc
verbindet wenn auf der anderen seite
mehr von diesen euphorisierenden
botenstoffen dem dopamin eben
ausgeschüttet und das führt dazu vor
allem im belohnungszentrum zum beispiel
im menschlichen gehirn das eben der
mensch sich vor gefühlen diesen
rauschzustand in erlebt cannabis ist
verboten und das hat fatale folgen
während auf jeder flasche alkohol der
exakte alkoholanteil steht ist der thc
gehalt in cannes abels höchst
unterschiedlich das kann zwischen fünf
und 20 prozent liegen
das heißt was ein gestern noch leicht
berauscht hat das kann ein morgen schon
umhauen es gibt
einerlei kontrollen und besonders fatal
ist dass bei haschisch dem gestressten
harz der cannabispflanze
das harz das wird nämlich gerne
gestreckt und in den einschlägigen foren
da ist die rede von plastik gummi
schuhcreme haarspray talkum und so
weiter und so fort der fantasie sind da
offensichtlich keine grenzen gesetzt und
das kann katastrophale folgen haben bis
zu bleibenden hirnschäden am
beliebtesten ist deswegen immer noch der
joint viel tabak mit marihuana gemischt
und so lange man dann noch die
zusammenhängenden blütenstände
verarbeitet ist das risiko gestreckten
stoff in der hand haben geringer wobei
auch hier schon glas oder auch sand
entdeckt worden sind
eines ist verrückt cannabis scheint
wissenschaftlich noch nicht so richtig
untersucht worden zu sein
so gibt zum beispiel eine studie die
cannabis die verursachung von
schizophrenie unterstellt dies aber
methodisch wohl nicht ganz astrein und
die arbeitsgemeinschaften der
wissenschaftlichen medizinischen
fachgesellschaften die sagt sogar die
cannabis nachgesagte wirkung von der
verursachung von lethargie und
passivität die ist überhaupt nicht
erwiesen
eins ist allerdings sicher thc der
wirkstoff der beeinträchtigt die
konzentrationsfähigkeit für viele
stunden und cannabis konsumenten
berichten von einer folge des
cannabiskonsums die sich wohlwollend von
der von alkohol unterscheidet die artus
sage ich mal hat er so bei cannabis auch
ein bisschen anders als bei alkohol
alkohol habe ich häufig beobachtet dass
es viele aggressiv macht will und wollen
ist dass er
freundliche stimmung aufruft möglich ist
aber wie bei alkohol bei unter 18
jährigen die hirnschädigung wobei auch
die studie ist umstritten aber vor sich
ist da in jedem fall geboten sicher nach
gewesen ist die medizinische wirkung von
thc also von tetrahydrocannabinol das
wird gegen spasmen oder gegen erbrechen
eingesetzt
wenn aber jetzt cannabis ja eigentlich
fast weniger gefährlich als alkohol es
gibt keine toten
warum ist es dann verboten schuld daran
ist dieser mann frau der erste könig von
ägypten bis 1951 er wollte in den 20er
jahren dass sein volk strebsamer wird
und bestand deshalb auf dem weltweiten
verbot von cannabis das tat er mit
seiner delegation auf der opium
konferenz in genf 1925 und deutschland
stimmte unter anderem zu und jetzt wird
pikant weil ägypten im gegenzug den
import von kokain von der deutschen
merck und heroin von der deutschen bahn
ag duldete das nennt man eine win win
situation
was meint ihr sollen alle drogen
verboten werden oder soll cannabis wie
alkohol und tabak erlaubt werden
diskutiert es hier unter dem video wenn
er meint das ist ein wichtiges thema ist
dann teilt es auf facebook like tess und
twittert es ich bin sehr gespannt
mehr zum thema gibt es auf top 10
die zehn stärksten cannabis sorten und
hier gehts zum letzten video schwarze
löcher und ihr dunkles geheimnis bis
dann bleibt dran